[Music]
all right in nearly 18 months the
expanded unemployment benefits that
started during the coronavirus pandemic
come to an end as of yesterday the move
affecting 8.9 million jobless americans
so how will this impact the economy and
struggling labor market after all
there's about 10 million jobs open right
now let's ask charles payne host of
making money on fox business you know
the republican states have already
started taking away this 300 a week uh
what's the results there what do you
expect the results be now
you've had some people go back to work
but i think the the mistake is thinking
that this whole thing will be
instantaneous uh you know some people
have gotten relief for going on a year
and a half 18 months some longer people
have money in the bank uh households
have the greatest balance sheets that
they've ever had before so
if the unemployment checks stopped today
you've got a whole lot of people who've
already said in surveys and other
questionnaires that they'll wait they've
got enough money socked away they
haven't paid the rent
a lot of folks you know they've had
moratoriums and student loans they've
had moratoriums on mortgages rents uh
they've gotten paid big time money
they've gotten checks from a variety of
federal programs people actually have
money so it's a mistake to say okay
xyz red state stopped on this date and
the next day jobs didn't explode people
didn't go back to work they will
eventually as that money runs out uh but
you're not going to see an immediate
reaction so i thought joe manchin is
trying to save the country from the 3.5
trillion we can't afford which is
basically cradle to grave social safety
net
which is a nice thought but it's
unaffordable in our current system but
doesn't seem to matter democrats but in
that column i saw this one line i want
to bounce off you manchin complained in
his op-ed the republicans used the
reconciliation package of trump's tax
cuts in 2017 and it only benefited rich
investors more than workers while adding
1 trillion to the national debt do you
want to take on that statement because i
don't believe it's rooted in fact
well first of all all of this money
printing whether it's the federal
reserve or the federal government
is going to help corporations because
eventually people go out and spend that
money and guess what it goes to the
bottom line and when those bottom lines
get fat stocks go up here's the
beautiful thing if you live in america
you can open up an account and be on in
the market by 9 30 today so those kind
of things are just just completely just
landmines and mistruths and disingenuous
now as far as the labor market is
concerned the wage market is concerned
the very month that president trump's
tax cuts went into effect blue-collar
wages surged they went ahead of real
they went ahead of inflation they grew
well over three percent every single
month year over year and it was the
first time in more than a decade brian
more than a decade that blue collar
wages outpaced not only overall wages
but inflation and the reason i bring up
inflation it's key
every single month this year inflation
month-to-month has wiped out any job
gains and here's real it's really kind
of interesting since that 1.9 trillion
dollars went into effect the so-called
rescue plan here's what your wheel wages
did not not weigh just nominal wages but
when you go to the supermarket in in
april they were down 3.7 percent year
over year and made 2.8 percent in june
1.6 percent in july 1.2
wages are actually down because we've
put so much money into this economy that
prices have gone through the roof
someone should talk about inflation
because if you're worried about votes
that's when people say wow why am i
getting less than paying more when i go
shopping
who did what and who's responsible and
by the way morgan stanley now predicts
the economy will grow annually by just
2.9 percent instead of 6.5 real quick on
that
yeah they dropped their number four
times in the last four weeks we've got
some problems here people have to
eventually get back to work i understand
you know if you want to hold out you
want more money you want hybrid work you
don't want to go in there's a lot of
things happening psychological economic
but we're in a dangerous place we could
squander the greatest jobs market ever
if people don't start to go back to work
charles payne we're going to watch on
making money at two o'clock eastern time
on fox business if that's okay with you